welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for star wars and or or ander if
you're still in skarsgard a prequel
series to rogue one coming september
21st on disney plus first three episodes
dropping all at once this [ __ ] is filled
with stunning cinematic imagery shot on
location they tell us which i assume
includes the full-sized planet of
coruscant that disney has on a backlot i
think this show is gonna rock so let's
break down this trailer frame by frame
for some details you might have missed
here we go
[Music]
okay the trailer opens with these hikers
climbing through the real-life scottish
highlands series creator tony gilroy
confirmed to empire magazine that andor
is the first star wars disney plus
series to not use that volume technology
since it was created and used for the
mandalorian in the book of boba fett and
obi-wan kenobi and while i loved what
they were able to accomplish with that
you could totally feel the difference
here like we've seen these scottish
hills in a number of titles over the
years so we just have an innate
understanding of how vast they are so to
compare this terrain with an imperial
star destroyer just more effectively
shocks us with scale than we would be if
we saw it looming over a fictional
extraterrestrial landscape i mean take
it from a guy who just last week and
hiked through the redwood forest aka
endor earth's nature can be surreal and
beautiful enough to evoke that classic
star wars rush of escapism i love the
the of a sonic boom announcing the
arrival of the imperials
and if you look closely you can see two
tie fighters just over the ridge
sneaking up behind them and while we're
looking at that background notice how
the water level in background is much
higher than where the valley dips below
them so i assume this must be that
location where we later see a dam i'll
go into why that dam might be there
later on but we gotta talk about the
amazing sound design of this star
destroyer as it looms over the woman its
shadows release the sounds of a
helicopter blade worrying
yeah helicopter sounds reminding us of
military superpowers invasions like the
us and vietnam which george lucas has
said inspired the original trilogy
especially return of the jedi i also
love how the immensity of this passing
star destroyer freaking shakes the
camera just evoking that whole aesthetic
of a war documentary and choosing
scotland here as the hiding place of
these bands of rebels might be
intentional as george lucas did tend to
cast actors with polsh british accents
as imperial officers which is later
justified in universe as the imperial
rank and file tending to come from the
core worlds where people were more
educated and talk with a certain affect
whereas the rebels tended to come from
all over so we think of this scottish
terrain with british exit imperials
looming over them i mean just talk to
annie scott about the long history of
the british depression of scotland i am
not filled with enough whiskey or shrek
rage to do this history justice let's
move on
to steal from the empire
you just walk in like you belong
[Music]
they're so proud of themselves
okay i am really digging the music here
it actually sounds like a child
vocalizing syllables
[Music]
the composer of the series is the
amazing nicholas patel who does hbo's
succession and he told variety about
creating a soundscape that he called
orchestral plus with a mix of textures
and sound worlds whatever this is this
kid's voice just fits so well over the
shot of who i assume is young cassie and
andor overlooking this vast terraced pit
not terrorist terrorist looks like a
mining quarry or maybe the attempts to
build a subterranean base now i counted
because that that's just what i do i
counted 26 terrorist layers on the far
side and then looking over on the near
side the right of the frame each of
those layers has like three to six
smaller terraced steps to it meaning
that whoever dug this dug several
hundred layers deep like this went
like a hundred times and it looks as
though after they dug all of that there
were some cave-ins in various spots
maybe from bombing raids so if this is
young cassian here this probably would
not have been an imperial operation or
rather something dug by separatists or
by republic forces during the clone wars
and just left behind after this planet
was ravaged because if you look at the
trees in the foreground there they look
pretty burned up now this kid climbs
into a shaft reminding me at least of
the early force awakens footage of rey
scavenging the rex star destroyer after
the battle jakku then we get an overhead
shot showing the imperial senate of
coruscant where if you look at that
central floor it has been redesigned
with a six-pronged imperial crest so at
this point in history the empire kept
the senate around but really as kind of
a phony government to maintain order
until they can launch the death star and
just completely do away with the senate
and then rely on the regional governors
to keep them in line but in this point
in history senators like mon mothma and
bail organa will continue to serve in
hopes of enacting some good but secretly
they're just playing both sides really
supporting rebel insurgencies and we end
this section on this imperial officer
played by anton lesser aka kwyburn from
game of thrones it's just super
unnerving how white and clean this room
is as a contrast to the downright filth
of the exteriors of this trailer let's
move on so fat and satisfied
they can't imagine
that someone like me
[Music]
would ever get inside their house
okay here we get a close-up of young
cassian's shoes where it looks like he's
stuffed rags in there maybe a socks so
the shoes fit better actually his puffy
yellow top looks like it might be one of
those workman's jackets it's worn by
scrap workers and other parts of the
trailer so this kid might have found all
these clothes and then tied all the
loose fabric around him so it just fits
them better i like how in this control
room the display is glitching it
actually has the same black background
analog display style that we saw in the
original a new hope when they were going
through the death star battle plans or
when we saw those death star battle
plans where they were being uploaded and
transferred in the final scenes of rogue
one i just love how consistent all this
is and yeah it looks like cassian as an
adult will spend some time either in
disguise as an imperial cadet or maybe
just as someone who actually served the
empire for a period of time but maybe
got flipped had some kind of dual
loyalty i mean the guy is a spy and as
we saw with tala and obi-wan kenobi it
seems like there are people all over the
empire in these kind of positions next
clip cassian ander
the empire is choking us so slowly
we're starting not to notice
what i'm asking is this
wouldn't you rather give it all
to something real
okay stellan skarsgard plays lutheran
real a rebel but with an interesting
double life that we'll get to later here
he recruits cassian saying the empire is
choking us so slowly we're starting not
to notice i love it describing the way
the empire has warped these societies
from the ground up normalizing the
authoritarian rule it also reminds us of
how darth vader choked admiral mati so
slowly at first said monty didn't even
realize he was suffocating and that is
what the empire does folks whether it's
entire subjugated societies or its own
ranks it's an equal opportunity choker
denise goff's character marches in
flanked by death troopers remember death
troopers are the taller elite commandos
who we saw with krannic at the beginning
of rogue one closed captioning confirms
that her character's name is dedra miro
judging from her white uniform she's
probably part of the isb that's the
imperial security bureau the ss style
division that we also saw in rogue one
you don't mess around with these guys
andrea's character flees the local
patrolman there's an armish sign to her
right that ends with y o and then
there's a pink one on the right side
that's just too blurry to make out i
tried so hard for you all to figure out
what it said and i failed i failed i'm
sorry but it's probably something like
ewok burgers you know that is no
consequence of the plot a massive
section of a ship collapses presumably
this is part of the scene that we saw in
early concept art of republic era
venator-class star destroyers being
dismantled but those parts reconstructed
into the imperial era star destroyers
then cassian walks through this scrap
yard and we actually learned that this
planet is called ferrix but this video
is brought to you by the ridge the ridge
wallet is light and sleek and industrial
it's designed to fit in your front
pocket unlike those bulky old school
wallets and make you look like you're
smuggling an 80s car phone in your back
pocket check it out there are over 30
colors including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash card
and
gold dollars this is what they call the
black damascus only the finest for my
front pockets every ridge wallet comes
with a lifetime guarantee and they'll
let you test drive it for 45 days and
send it back for a full refund if you
don't love it the wallets have over 40
000 five-star reviews it's made with an
rfid blocking technology that protects
you from those digital pickpocketers
they also have other cool products like
this commuter backpack it's weatherproof
and great for toting around a laptop
this month actually marks nine years
since the ridge started and they're
celebrating with a special sale so get
15 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge.com
new rockstars and use code new rockstars
find the link in the video's description
let's move on
[Music]
i need all the heroes i can get
for the greater good
call it what you will let's call it
war so lutheran lands on a new planet
and cloaks himself his speeder cuts
across a checkerboard patchwork of
different crops being farmed the variety
of terrain it's just so interesting
looks like we got dusty orange clay then
blue water but also green swamp and then
we see her old friends the partisans you
remember them saw gerrera's group from
rogue one who accompanied him on jedha
some familiar faces show up here one of
the two tubes brothers i'm assuming this
is edrio tutubes he keeps watch over
this hidden base and down below is a
starfighter an early x-wing so in star
wars canonical history x-wings only now
started to be rolled out they came from
the incom corporation's redesigns from
their clone wars era starfighters like
the z95 these x-wings were originally
intended for the imperial navy but the
empire got cheap and then went with the
cnr fleet system's less expensive tie
fighter line which allowed the rebel
alliance then to adopt the x-wave as
their predominant starfighter so yeah
this would definitely be one of the
earlier x-wings we've seen in the
live-action star wars chronology and if
you look down on that lower level you
could barely make out more of that's a
white bird fella who's part of the
partisans in rogue one inside as the
partisans raised their guns the closest
to us i think that might be a younger we
see cubie the talpini played by warwick
davis in rogue one we pretty cool
warwick came back for this too then
forrest whitaker returns as saw gerrera
leader of the partisans notice his hair
is less gray than we see him in rogue
one but here he bears that scar across
his face that he had when we last saw
him in bad batch saw says let's call it
war because this guy has always been
leading up the most extreme branch of
the rebel alliance his methods looked
down on as too violent and terroristic
for the likes of mon mothma let's move
on
there's fermenting out there some
pockets of fermenting
you're in my net
are you a fish
are you a thief
okay three mobile tac pods descend to
ferrix and we get a close-up of kyle
solar's inspector character named cyril
karn who in the previous teaser is seen
reacting to a bounty hollow projection
of cassie and andor telling us that he
is going to be pursuing cassian
meanwhile there's another guy in his
unit sergeant linus mosque who says
there's fomenting out there sir pockets
of fermenting and i already love the
writing on this show pockets of
fomenting it's just such a specific way
to describe an uprising but in a dead
serious tone i'm gonna start using that
like uh-oh someone tweeted implying not
every second of iron fist or agents of
shield as mcu cannon pockets of
fermenting forming pockets of fermenting
as mosque exits this attack pod the
oramesh above the ramp reads caution i
was able to make out that one then a
lambda class shuttle lands on ferrix and
dedramiro meets with other officers as
they observe a hollow display of their
base miro says to adria arona's
character who's captured interrogating
her you're in my net are you a fish or
are you a thief which is another
interesting line because neither option
is really great for her if she's a thief
she'll be turned over to the local law
enforcement but if she's a fish it means
she is a rebel insurgent that miro was
trying to catch in that net onto the
next clip
you're slipping
i'm not sleeping
i've just been hiding for too long
interesting so here we see luthen's
double life or maybe part of his
backstory he puts on several golden
rings and dresses and fancy robes as he
welcomes mon mothma into this shop on
coruscant a location with a trove of
antiquities whoever his partner in crime
is here maybe his daughter is named clea
and she says he's slipping so are they
both playing parts are they embedded on
coruscant trying to get close to vips
and if so is lutheran aware of mon
mothma's true loyalties yet are both of
these people putting up fronts trying to
suss each other out all we know is that
lutheran has long hair here but then in
different parts of the series he cuts
his hair and there's a scene where he's
playing a pretty significant role
piloting a starfighter in a battle with
tie fighters he shoots down a tie bomber
as he barrels towards this interesting
looking star destroyer with an alternate
design including some dishes on the
sides according to lucasfilm's bill
sostak this is designer colin cantwell's
early early 1974 proto star destroyer
concept art which also showed up in the
imperial recruitment hologram and solo a
star wars story i love it when they work
in the concept art like this on to the
next clip
as long as everyone thinks i'm an
irritation
there's a good chance they'll miss what
i'm really doing what are you really
doing
wow so some intensely detailed aerial
shots of coruscant and i love how here
as opposed to the prequels much of the
color in life seems to have been drained
from the coruscant cityscape now it is
much more of a brutalist concrete
fortress that runs on clockwork
manamapha speaks in their imperial
senate and she tells a colleague as long
as everyone thinks i'm an irritation
there's a good chance they'll miss out
on what i'm really doing now our friend
is a new character named tay coma some
thought he looks like former chancellor
finis valorum but this is not to terran
stamp this is ben miles whom you might
know as peter townsend in the early
seasons of the crown so mon mata during
these years really gained a reputation
as a kind of a pacifist she spoke out on
various human rights issues the series
will give us a sense of how the senator
is really using irritating parliamentary
tactics to look like a career politician
but really this is a smoke screen to
mask her actual covert efforts now a few
years into this she's going to
eventually speak out publicly condemning
the gorman massacre and resign from the
senate which will lead to the empire
labeling her as a traitor which is how
she ends up with crew of the ghost and
rebels but until then may mon mothma's
political games begin it's a very quick
shot of fiona shaw's character marva she
sheds a tear and the show's new droid b2
emo or b2 or just b who's also on
display at comic con described as a very
old and weary ground mech salvage assist
unit that has been towing scrap war the
andor family for years so he and andor
go way back now the character clea also
goes through a hair and wardrobe change
she tells someone this is what
revolution looks like interesting
sentence structure there because the
first teaser ended with marva saying
that's what a reckoning sounds like i
see next trailer it's gonna be this is
what fermenting tastes like onto the
final clip
okay three rebels run along that dam in
a location that looks a lot like those
scottish highlands that i talked about
later so maybe this is why the water
level was higher in some parts of the
hills and others maybe a rebel mission
will be to blow this dam because
remember the first teaser showed water
pooled in a lake where some imperial
machinery was being built in this lake
and launched out of it so maybe by
draining this lake they will stymie
whatever that imperial operation is then
a shot of laborers in white uniforms
running barefoot down a tunnel that
might be a prison camp actually looks
like cassian is among them probably
helping them break out of it this could
be the dangerous mission on aldani that
was mentioned at that comic-con display
i'm wondering if this could be the labor
camp where engineers build kx series
droids this could be where cassian meets
and reprograms k2so then there's this
interesting looking figure performing a
medical procedure with eyepieces smushed
into his face at summer comparing to maz
kanata but this is a completely
different race in moscow moscona did not
have four arms
and then this completely heavenly shot
of a drop ship out running a debris
field over a cloud layer never has
complete chaos looked more beautiful i
mean maybe the ship is outrunning the
debris of a shattered star destroyer
that's now raining down on this planet i
don't know what's going on it just looks
awesome and we end with one tie fire
firing on another tie fighter i assume
it's because cassian stole it folks this
trailer freaking rules and i cannot wait
to dive into this show into this era of
star wars history because i love rogue
one i love it more and more every year
and i'm completely surprised by how good
this show is looking i mean going into
this here obi-wan kenobi andor i was
like open with kenobi it's going to be
what i feast on and now i can't wait for
andor yes andor hey follow me on
instagram and twitter at avas following
rockstar subscribe to rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you